Parents
I Get more emails about parents
from parents, talking to me about their kids than ever...
more messages, more reaching out, more than ever
So said something in the middle of my project, might as well address it
Parents
Please let them win, on their terms not yours
Your children
The children are not a direct indication of who you are...
They are a by-product, There's proxies, There's things
but so many of you are deploying your insecurities about...
yourself, on your children because you genuinely care
about what people around you are saying about them;
other families,
other friends, other relatives talking about your kids,
you value more to them
you value their POVs, excuse me,
More than listening to your own children and when I say listening
You have to be able to decode an 8 year old, 13 year old, 17 year old,20 year old;
It's not necessarily the words, when you actually get into an emotional or real conversation...
it's their actions; it is your job as a leader of a business,
of a family, to reverse engineer the players in the game and put them in the best position to succeed
And the thought that so many of you
Thank you
And the thought that so many of you are parenting your children
predicated on your short-term
fulfillment to other people's opinions
devastates the shit out of me
And one day it will devastate you too... it probably devastates you right now
And so that line hit you directly in your fucking heart, or your brain, or your consciousness,
please do something about it
I may never make a video more important to me than this; I'm a  byproduct of *Sobs* most incredible parents
who disproportionately put me in a position to succeed
because they'll were confident in who they were and did not allow other people to judge them
and allowed me..
to live in happiness and be who I was
And I read a hundred *pauses *
messages a day
from parents them know they're not
so please parents please understand that your concern of being judged
by artificial truths
is positioning your children
not to fulfill the happiness that you have to want for them
Your inability to understand how the landscape changes over the next 30-40 years
Is over protecting your children from the victories that they deserve
It also creates an unbelievable weakness for them not to be able to deal, I'm able to deal
because my mother and father put me into a framework
that allowed me to fail, it allowed me to be me
and I learned... I learned every day
of my shortcomings and other people's opinions
Really easy way to not be bullied is to not hear them in the first place
Please don't let your insecurities be imposed and please don't hide them
Under the false statements that - you're trying to do what's right for them
What's right for them
Is to give them freedom to be themselves as long it is noble and fair
Do not judge their creativity or the angles they see that you do not see now, because history has proven
it's practical to understand you can't see it ,they can
please....
Please...